de 400 millones de años
una tan ubicua que funciona en casi todos los ecosistemas del mundo,
tan grande que puede conectar a millones de comerciantes simultáneamente,
y tan persistente
que sobrevivió a las extinciones masivas.
Está aquí, ahora mismo, bajo nuestros pies.
Simplemente no se puede ver.
Y a diferencia de las economías humanas
que dependen de la cognición para tomar decisiones,
los comerciantes en este mercado, mendigan, piden prestado, roban, engañan,
todo en ausencia de pensamiento.
Muy escondido a nuestros ojos, las raíces de las plantas
están colonizadas por un hongo llamado micorriza arbuscular.
El hongo forma estas complejas redes subterráneas
de filamentos finos más delgados, incluso, que hilos de algodón.
Se sigue uno de estos hongos,
y conecta múltiples plantas simultáneamente.
Pueden pensarlo como un sistema de metro subterráneo,
donde cada raíz es una estación,
donde los recursos se cargan y descargan.
Y también es muy denso,
aproximadamente la longitud de muchos metros, incluso 1 km
en un solo gramo de tierra.
Esa es la longitud de 10 campos de fútbol.
en solo un dedal de tierra.
Y está en todas partes.
Así, si pasaron por un árbol, un arbusto, una vid, incluso una pequeña hierba,
pasaron por una red de micorrizas.
Aproximadamente el 80 % de todas las especies de plantas
está asociado con estos hongos micorrícicos.
¿Qué tiene que ver una raíz cubierta de hongos
con nuestra economía global?
¿Y por qué como bióloga evolutiva he pasado los últimos 10 años de mi vida
aprendiendo jerga económica?
Lo primero que deben entender
es que los acuerdos comerciales hechos por los socios plantas y hongos
son sorprendentemente similares
a los hechos por nosotros,
pero quizás aún más estratégicos.
Plantas y hongos socios,
no están intercambiando acciones y bonos,
están intercambiando recursos esenciales,
y para el hongo, son azúcares y grasas.
Obtiene todo su carbono directamente del socio planta.
Cada año, aproximadamente cinco mil millones de toneladas de carbono
de las plantas ingresan a esta red subterránea.
Para la raíz, lo que se necesita es fósforo y nitrógeno,
entonces intercambiando su carbono
obtienen acceso a todos los nutrientes recolectados por esa red fúngica.
Para hacer el intercambio,
el hongo penetra en la célula raíz del huésped
y forma una pequeña estructura llamada arbúsculo,
que en latín significa "arbolito".
Pueden pensar en esto como la bolsa de valores física
del mercado comercial.
Hasta ahora, parece muy armonioso.
¿Correcto? Te rasco la espalda, tú rascas la mía
ambos socios obtienen lo que necesitan.
Pero aquí es donde tenemos que hacer una pausa,
para entender el poder de la evolución y la selección natural.
No hay espacio para los comerciantes aficionados en este mercado.
Hacer la estrategia comercial correcta
determina quién vive y quién muere.
Uso la palabra estrategia,
pero, por supuesto, las plantas y los hongos no tienen cerebro.
Hacen estos intercambios
en ausencia de cualquier cosa que consideremos como pensamiento.
Pero, como científicos, usamos términos de comportamiento
como "estrategia"
para describir comportamientos en ciertas condiciones,
acciones y reacciones,
que en realidad están programados en el ADN del organismo.
Comencé a estudiar estas estrategias comerciales
cuando tenia 19 años y
vivía en las selvas tropicales de Panamá.
Todos, entonces, estaban interesados en esta increíble diversidad en el terreno.
Y era hiperdiversidad. Estas son las selvas tropicales.
Pero yo estaba interesada en la complejidad subterránea.
Sabíamos que las redes existían y que eran importantes,
y voy a decirlo de nuevo, por importante quiero decir importante,
ya que es la base de toda la nutrición vegetal
y toda la diversidad que se ve en la superficie.
Pero en ese momento, no sabíamos cómo funcionaban estas redes.
No sabíamos cómo funcionaban.
¿Por qué solo ciertas plantas interactúan con ciertos hongos?
Adelantemos a cuando comencé mi propio grupo,
y realmente comenzamos a jugar con este mercado comercial.
Verán, manipularíamos las condiciones.
Creamos un buen socio comercial cultivando una planta al sol
y un socio comercial pobre al cultivarlo a la sombra.
Luego los conectaríamos con una red fúngica.
Y descubrimos que los hongos eran consistentemente buenos
en discriminar entre buenos y malos socios comerciales.
Asignarían más recursos a la planta huésped dándoles más carbono.
Ejecutamos los experimentos recíprocos
en que inoculamos una planta huésped con hongos buenos y malos,
y también fueron buenas para discriminar entre estos socios comerciales.
Lo que se tiene allí son las condiciones perfectas para que surja un mercado.
Es un mercado simple,
pero, no obstante, es un mercado
donde el mejor socio comercial es constantemente favorecido.
¿Pero es un mercado justo?
Aquí es donde deben entender que, como los humanos,
las plantas y los hongos son increíblemente oportunistas.
Hay evidencia de que el hongo, una vez que penetra en la célula vegetal,
en realidad puede secuestrar el sistema de absorción de nutrientes de la planta.
Lo hace suprimiendo la capacidad de la planta.
de tomar nutrientes del suelo.
Esto crea una dependencia de la planta del hongo.
Es una adicción falsa, de algún tipo,
por lo que la planta tiene que alimentar al hongo
solo para obtener acceso a los recursos alrededor de su propia raíz.
También hay evidencia de que los hongos son buenos
para inflar el precio de los nutrientes.
Lo hacen extrayendo los nutrientes del suelo,
pero luego, en lugar de intercambiarlos con el anfitrión,
los acaparan en su red,
haciendo que no estén disponibles para la planta y otros hongos competidores.
Economía básica,
a medida que la disponibilidad de recursos disminuye, el valor aumenta.
La planta se ve obligada a pagar más por la misma cantidad de recursos.
Pero no todo está a favor del hongo.
Las plantas también pueden ser extremadamente astutas.
Hay algunas orquídeas.
--y siempre pienso que las orquídeas parecen las más tortuosas
de las especies de plantas en el mundo--
y hay algunas orquídeas
que solo tocan directamente en la red
y roban todo su carbono.
Estas orquídeas, ni siquiera hacen hojas verdes para fotosintetizar.
Son solo blancas.
En lugar de fotosintetizar,
aprovechan la red,
roban el carbono
y no dan nada a cambio.
Creo que es justo decir que este tipo de parásitos
también florece en nuestros mercados humanos.
Cuando comenzamos a descodificar estas estrategias,
aprendimos algunas lecciones.
Y la primera fue que no hay altruismo en este sistema.
No hay favores comerciales.
No vemos evidencia fuerte
del hongo que ayuda a las plantas moribundas o que luchan
a menos que beneficie directamente al hongo en sí.
No estoy diciendo si esto es bueno o malo.
A diferencia de los humanos, un hongo, claro, no puede juzgar su moralidad.
Y como bióloga,
no estoy abogando por este tipo de dinámica despiadada del mercado neoliberal
promulgada por los hongos.
Pero el sistema de comercio,
nos proporciona un punto de referencia
para estudiar cómo se ve una economía
cuando ha sido moldeada por selección natural
por cientos de millones de años
en ausencia de moralidad,
cuando las estrategias solo se basan
en la recopilación y el procesamiento de información,
no contaminado por cognición:
sin celos, sin rencor,
pero no hay esperanza, no hay alegría.
Así que hemos progresado
al decodificar los principios comerciales más básicos en este punto,
pero como científicos siempre queremos ir un paso más allá,
y estamos interesados en dilemas económicos más complejos.
Y específicamente estamos interesados en los efectos de la desigualdad.
La desigualdad se ha convertido realmente en una característica definitoria
del panorama económico actual.
Pero los desafíos de la desigualdad
no son exclusivos del mundo humano.
Creo que como humanos tendemos a pensar que todo es único para nosotros,
pero organismos en la naturaleza
debe enfrentar una variación incesante en su acceso a los recursos.
¿Cómo funciona un hongo que nuevamente puede tener metros de largo
para cambiar su estrategia comercial cuando se expone simultáneamente
a una parcela rica y una pobre?
Y, más generalmente,
¿cómo los organismos en la naturaleza utilizan el comercio en su beneficio
cuando se enfrentan a la incertidumbre
en cuanto a su acceso a los recursos?
Aquí es donde tengo que contarles un secreto:
estudiar comercio subterráneo es increíblemente difícil.
No puede ver dónde o cuándo tienen lugar importantes acuerdos comerciales.
Entonces nuestro grupo ayudó a crear un método, una tecnología,
por la que podríamos etiquetar nutrientes con nanopartículas,
nanopartículas fluorescentes llamadas puntos cuánticos.
Lo que los puntos cuánticos nos permiten hacer
es en realidad iluminar los nutrientes
para que podamos seguir visualmente sus movimientos
a través de la red fúngica
y en la raíz del anfitrión.
Esto nos permite finalmente ver lo invisible, para que podamos estudiar
cómo los hongos negocian a pequeña escala con sus plantas anfitrionas.
Para estudiar la desigualdad,
expusimos una red fúngica
a estas concentraciones variables de fósforo fluorescente,
imitando parcelas de abundancia y escasez
a través de este paisaje artificial.
Luego cuantificamos cuidadosamente el comercio de hongos.
Y encontramos dos cosas.
Lo primero que encontramos
fue que la desigualdad alentó al hongo a comerciar más.
Puedo usar la palabra "alentado" o "estimulado" o "forzado",
pero la conclusión es que, en comparación con las condiciones de control,
la desigualdad se asoció con mayores niveles de comercio.
Esto es importante,
porque sugiere que evolucionar una asociación comercial en la naturaleza
puede ayudar a hacer frente a los organismos,
a la incertidumbre de acceder a los recursos.
En segundo lugar, encontramos que, expuesto a la desigualdad,
el hongo movería recursos de la parcela rica de la red,
transportarlos activamente al lado pobre de la red.
Por supuesto, podríamos ver esto
porque las parcelas estaban fluorescentes en diferentes colores.
Al principio, este resultado fue increíblemente desconcertante.
¿Fue para ayudar al lado pobre de la red?
No. Descubrimos que el hongo ganó más al mover primero los recursos.
a donde la demanda era mayor.
Simplemente cambiando en qué parte de la red se comercializaba el hongo,
podría manipular el valor de esos recursos.
Esto nos estimuló a profundizar más en cómo se comparte la información.
Sugiere un alto nivel de sofisticación,
o al menos un nivel medio de sofisticación
en un organismo sin cognición.
¿Cómo es que un hongo puede detectar las condiciones del mercado en toda su red
y luego hacer cálculos de dónde y cuándo comerciar?
Así que queríamos buscar información y cómo se comparte en esta red,
cómo el hongo integra las señales.
Para hacerlo, hay que sumergirse profundamente
y obtener una resolución más alta en la red misma.
Comenzamos a estudiar flujos complejos dentro de la red de hifas.
Lo que están viendo ahora es una red fúngica viva
con el contenido celular moviéndose a través de él.
Esto está sucediendo en tiempo real;
pueden ver la marca de tiempo allí arriba.
Esto está sucediendo ahora. Este video no está acelerado.
Esto está sucediendo bajo nuestros pies ahora.
Y hay un par de cosas que quiero que noten.
Se acelera, se ralentiza, cambia de dirección.
Ahora estamos trabajando con biofísicos
para tratar de diseccionar esta complejidad.
¿Cómo utiliza el hongo estos complejos patrones de flujo
para compartir y procesar información
y tomar estas decisiones comerciales?
¿Los hongos son mejores para hacer cálculos comerciales que nosotros?
Aquí es donde potencialmente podemos tomar prestados modelos de la naturaleza.
Dependemos cada vez más de los algoritmos informáticos.
para hacernos negocios rentables en escalas de tiempo de fracción de segundo.
Pero los algoritmos informáticos y los hongos,
ambos operan de manera similar, sin cognición.
Los hongos resultan ser una máquina viviente.
¿Qué pasaría si comparamos y hacemos competir
las estrategias comerciales de estos dos?
¿Quién ganaría?
¿El pequeño capitalista que ha existido
desde antes de la caída de los dinosaurios?
Mi dinero está con el hongo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)